[Music]
so truck drivers
that are going across the nation
are now trying to find ways to avoid
going through chicago
why do you think that is and it's not
because of murder or anything like that
i thought it was a gunfight
baby the crossfire tyrant that's what
they call it yeah no i thought they did
a lot of uh
robberies and stuff like the truck guys
but it's not even to do with that oh
they don't want to weigh in because
their pizza sucks
deep ones yeah the super deep dish you
guys what's the debate you guys don't
like you don't like chicago pizza oh i
do i was just joking i like it if i have
the time to eat it like i order it and
it takes like two hours to make and they
have to eat with a knife and fork
because have you guys been to that place
and it was it mesa masa or whatever is
it like silver lake or echo park or
whatever but it's like this thick and
you can literally only have one slice
and you're done oh that's like chicago
deep dish style
of heavy yeah and you just fall asleep
in a restaurant
i like it because it's crispy on the
bottom he's like from experience i'm
telling you the only pizza that i really
like is the fictitious one from the
intro of ninja turtles movie oh it looks
so the one that they're all like the one
he cuts with the katana in the air
dude that would be cool cutting pizzas
with a freaking katana
it goes like this and then it lands on
each person's plate and it's splinter's
head all these glitters on them feel
like there's so many good business ideas
every time we talk about crap we need to
just say effort it just do it we're just
digital pizza katana pizza emt pizza
okay so here's here's an extra clue it
has something to do with tow truck
drivers
oh ron ron ron's in chicago do you know
about chicago i know deep dish pizza
maybe they're tow truck drivers they
don't are active so they gain a lot of
weight so they're probably avoiding
chicago so they don't eat the pizza and
therefore
investing in their health yeah i think
that's it i can't wait to be right
[Laughter]
i think they're towing the trucks like
the tow truck drivers are stopping to
get it uh deep this fish pizza and it's
taking two hours so the tow truck driver
comes and [ __ ] takes away the money
but now the customers are waiting two
hours longer
you don't have to do it that's the only
thing we have maybe maybe that would
happen
and as soon as they see that guy leave
their truck they're telling everybody
they don't give a [ __ ] he's like truck
drivers like stop on the side right to
like sleep like you have to take sleep
schedules they're probably towing them
with them in the truck it's a little
more nefarious than that they wake up
and then they're like what the [ __ ]
chicago is known for having a ton of
bridges via ducks you know parts where
the train runs right over
and uh these tow truck guys they'll wait
in their trucks right next to those
when a truck driver comes
and he's not sure if he can make it any
the tow truck driver see him looking and
checking they go oh you're good you're
good go ahead
and then they go and they get stuck
while they're stuck the tow truck guys
all roll in and they go oh we'll get it
out of there and even though the truck
driver's like no no please don't please
don't they latch on anyway and they take
the trailer away oh
but and then they go it'll just be a few
hundred bucks by the time those
those truck drivers get to the tow yard
they're charged upwards of 10 to 15k to
get their trailer out wow that is
very shady how do you feel about that
dang that's why tow truck industry has a
bad name
what's the honorable trump
but we give them like a 15 discount so
they feel better about it see that's the
only that's honorable
15k yeah now you pay 13 and a half when
i was a junior in high school i was uh
delivering uh pharmaceuticals to people
in santa ana and then pharmaceuticals
what a serious job is that for high
school
yeah i was outside i had performances i
had crazy at crazy credentials already i
was a rat yeah e cheese
lap in the shape of a triple a t-shirt
um
and i would drive like until i was
driving on the five and then my car died
because my aunt's car her engine just
[ __ ] died somehow and i was like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] cause then the power
steering turned off so i had to like
slowly uh move it and i know what to do
and i had like 20 uh pharmaceuticals on
me so i was like oh [ __ ] so i just
[ __ ] tossed it in the bush god you
know when you're a kid you don't know
what happens you think when you call the
tow truck you think the fire department
is going to come and everyone you think
he's the police you think you're ratting
yourself out in somewhere you drink all
the jokes
i can't have the tow truck to ever catch
me with you guys like don't arrest me
he's gonna tell me carmel's gonna know i
call the tow truck driver he comes and
then brings my car back from uh santa
ana all the way back to the 626
and when he came and i was oh is anyone
else coming like nah and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm just like looking at the bushes
there's 20 pills in there which is a lot
you know i'm like oh god and then when
they told me back to the 626 it was 80
bucks you're like damn man those pills
could have [ __ ] just for like 15
miles or something offer them some of
the pharmaceuticals as payments i should
have but i already throw it past the bus
you're too scared to go back to the bush
and grab it yeah i was gonna say did you
drive back to the boat no it's two
handfuls it was like you know the uh
where the freeway is like this and
there's like a fence and there's a bush
on the other side
so i wanted to throw it extra over then
if like cops came if they did come but
what is that look how far away there's
no way to throw like that far somewhere
out there there's a homeless man
smacking his teeth because he got
something
he's like what is this
[Laughter]
so yeah what do you think about tow
companies that camp certain problem
areas that's saying
that's illegal you can't do that right
no yeah it's actually illegal you're not
allowed to uh what the fudge is the word
scout poaching it's a poaching anyways
yeah it's illegal you're not allowed to
so even for police there's a specific
rule that um unless you have a police
contract you can't even tow the car
unless they request you so you have to
have a tow contract that's almost like
sabotage right like if you're waiting
right there
also on top of this by the time the guys
go to the tow yard and they go i didn't
sign off for that
the tow uh the tow truck guy has forged
their signature on the people yes
so illegal oh my god people did that but
they do it because these these truck
drivers they're on a schedule and they
just need their [ __ ] so they go all
right well i mean
you just got to pay for it we'll give it
to you so they're just like [ __ ] fine
and then they'll just charge it and then
later they try to dispute it with their
credit card company like hey
it's fraud but it's so hard after the
fact it's so hard yeah that's that's so
funny is that pretty high level in terms
of like scammy [ __ ] that's pretty
freaking
dirt ball level that sounds like some
mafia [ __ ] dude
yeah it's like a whole con we're not
just a mind your own business at the
supermarket and it's some guys like oh
you got a ding in the car i'll fix it oh
yeah get the [ __ ] away from me i've had
that like literally in traffic some guy
was like
what because i have a dent on my car
he's like hey uh i can fix that dent for
you i was like dude we're in the middle
of driving
oh my god damn you know like mobile dent
fixtures while you just give him a
chance bro it's all fast and fast he
jumps on my car
nah and the worst part is like when you
when they talk to you all loud and [ __ ]
and it catches you off guard and looking
at them kind of weird like no i don't
worry i'm a legit i'm like that makes
you look way more knowledgeable
check my yelp
i'm legit i got five stars like either i
go to your house or you come to my place
i'm like nah i don't do anything leave
me alone
at the supermarket yeah all the time
i've never had that happen i've actually
done it once before too back in arizona
on my old car you actually got the
service i actually got it so what
happened what was the experience i had a
jetta and it was like there's like a
ding in the back and i was like at the
supermarket and he came he's like hey i
could fix that for you
i was like yeah he's like yeah like 50
bucks and i was just like all right
that's not a bad deal he did this thing
where he like drilled a hole into it and
like put something in there like opened
up and then he like pulled it out and
like took out the damn the dentist fixed
but now that's all he did paint was all
messed up so like he like scraped it all
up and stuff so he's like yeah you just
have i can paint it for you i have some
black another 50 bucks
like a different upsell it's like a
different coat of black too yeah i was
just like no i'm good just watercolor
a paintbrush
he has a freaking easel yeah yeah let me
play the second guy popped up and goes
hey you got a hole i can feel that
like you need a paint car i could paint
that for you there's not starting
another guy hey i can start the car for
you there's a whole chorus line of
mechanics just popping up
why does the auto industry have such a
like shady feel to it you know i feel i
feel like every industry has a shady
feel to it like fighting has shady sides
to it like the towing has a ton of shady
size like this like people will camp out
let's say uh so there's called ppi's or
uh impounds or whatever right um you'll
camp out like let's say
a restaurant a cafe and they'll camp out
and there's let's say there's a theme
park next door and you're not supposed
to park at the restaurant a tow truck
company will freaking camp out and wait
for someone to park in front of the the
restaurant and walk to the theme park
they'll swoop it up within five minutes
that's illegal so as soon as like
someone comes out with like i don't know
disney paraphernalia they know they're
going to disneyland paraphernalia oh
mickey mouse ears
they're walking around skipping
no one does that at a liquor store oh i
can't wait
to get picking a slurpee my brother's a
mechanic and like he in arizona and he
told me because he works at the
dealership he was like you know there's
like specific hours right that each job
is supposed to take he's like that
doesn't mean it takes us that long to do
it he was like so i'll get jobs where
it's supposed to be like six hours of
label uh labor work he's like i'll
finish in an hour and a half but we
still get paid for six hours of labor
fail you for they build the customer for
six hours yeah that's that's not shady
though it can be it depends like so for
a mechanic right it can take one
mechanic six hours it'll take another
mechanic one hour yeah so do you charge
for your expertise you charge for your
time
that's a little bit different but if
you're really
like for towing right let's say
on average it should take an hour to do
something you charge four hours of labor
for it that's a little shady right
for something that takes skill yeah you
know um it's just because someone's
better or something your time yeah so
has it happened yet where you towed a
car and then they just abandoned it and
never came for it oh yeah all the time
dude i get free cars all the time you
guys have a yard let me get one let me
get one
hey how much you charging for those
three that's another revenue stream for
tow video you got one of those new
altimas man
you got a miata in there or what
2001 honda civic is dope yeah it doesn't
have wheels can i put a body kit on it
and are you like fast and furious i just
get a bunch of buddy club accessories
dude it's uh yeah it's crazy we just got
a 2017 mercedes s-class whoa i feel it
just happened yesterday i feel horrible
and they don't want it um no it's it's
totaled because uh frame damage no i
don't want that and what happens they
just leave it there um so if they total
that out and sometimes the insurance
company doesn't want to deal with it um
they'll just sit on do nothing and then
so we'll put a lien on it and then we'll
own it
how long how long until you own it
90 days 90 days so they don't do
anything about it 90 days but sometimes
the insurance company like sorry just
because there's so many hands involved
it takes forever as long as they
communicate with us like cool we won't
put a lien on it because we're we're
working we're working so is is earning a
card that way kind of a pain in the ass
or is it kind of like a yay we got a car
because like sometimes it sounds like
tow yards don't want that because it's
like a it's we you do want that because
it's a revenue stream oh and then so the
bigger tow yards they actually have
auctions and so they'll have like 50 or
100 cars they'll auction off and make
money that way wow i went to uh i went
to one of those looking for a car at one
of those auctions and then um at the tow
yard there were like a bunch of like
stray kittens
and then the guy in the cars yeah came
for free right running around the cars
and then the guy on the mic who's like
running and he's like djing at the same
time he's the owner of our yard he just
suddenly goes
it this is in huntington park by the way
he suddenly goes
all right anybody who buys a car today
you get a free
kitten actually don't even buy just take
a kitten man
please they need a home
he had a bar next to him where like you
could buy drinks what kind of awesome is
this holy christmas
party
no one was buying drinks obviously and
then one guy just walked over and looked
at it and the guy's all i see you
looking at that jack and he goes just
take it just take it
you want a jack and cotton cat yeah for
like
total cars do you guys do like pickle
parts and stuff
yeah we'll uh we'll send out to
junkyards and stuff like that but
usually most of these cars that get
totaled it's because the when you get
frame damage there's a lot of money to
fix so for like this 2017 s-class
frame damage it's not worth it like
they're gonna totally it's salvaged yeah
yeah it's salvaged and nobody wants a
salvaged car um but salvage cars are
freaking dope that's a whole nother game
i kind of like salvaged cars oh dude you
get such a good deal of salvage you know
if you don't ever plan on selling the
car again dude salvage is awesome as
long as you know how to repair it to
safety standards and whatnot um even a
lot of cars they're salvaged if the
airplane airbags deploy i don't like
damaged goods i love you stuff i do too
[Music]
you